it's been a great year for television
but unfortunately we can't say the same
for many of our favorite dearly departed
characters that's why we're paying
tribute to all the TV characters who
unexpectedly left us this year be
careful if you're not caught up on all
your favorite shows from this is us and
Walking Dead to Jessica Jones and even
new girl there are some major major
spoilers ahead millions of eager fans of
nbc's smash hit this is us knew that
pearson patriarch jack was going to die
but they weren't quite sure how On
February 4th the show finally revealed
exactly how Jack passed away in a
flashback sequence set in 1998 we see
the family slow-cooker short out
sparking a fire that quickly engulfs the
Pearson home
Jack wakes up in the middle of the night
smell smoke and turns into hero dad
getting his family out of the house with
a bed sheet rope then he goes back into
the burning house to save Louie the
family dog he's taken to the hospital to
attend to minor burns and all seems well
until your husband went into cardiac
arrest was catastrophic and I I'm afraid
we've lost to Carl Grimes grew up on TV
the son of Walking Dead protagonist Rick
Grimes Carl has been with the series
since episode 1 back in 2010 along the
way he endures tragedies and setbacks
including the death of his mother during
childbirth the loss of an eye and
various acts of evil by the show's
villains keeping Carl alive and safe as
the reason Rick never completely
crumbles and Carl keeps human decency
alive unfortunately his luck comes to an
end when a zombie finally takes a bite
out of Carl it's a death sentence but
not an immediate one giving Carl time to
say goodbye he hangs out with his little
sister Judith writes farewell letters
and then shoots himself before he can go
full Walker Carl wasn't the only Walking
Dead character whose death caught us by
surprise
Simon was Meegan's loyal selfless and
nasty second-in-command what did he get
for his constant devotion to the evil
leader of the Savior's violently choked
to death by his former boss his death
isn't completely out of the blue though
Simon had been pretty brashley making
some overtures to take over the
sanctuary
negan knows about it for a while but
rather than kill Simon right away he
gives Simon
few chances to prove himself or make it
right ultimately though Simon's luck
runs out when Meegan challenges him to a
fight with fatal consequences for the
loser
you got stages killer like a coward not
showing up one too many times
NCIS wound down its 15th season with a
heavily promoted plot the departure of
original character ABI
NCIS viewers worried that this new
spelled doom for the fan-favorite
character it definitely didn't look good
for ABI when an episode ended with ABI
and co-worker Clayton Reeves
seemingly shot by a mugger resolving
that cliffhanger ending next week's
episode found ducky sympathizing with
another coroner about the agony of
performing an autopsy on a former
colleague and abby died from a gunshot
[Music]
surprised she hadn't instead it was
Reeves who had died having selflessly
stepped in front of a be to take bullet
despite surviving and attacked by a
serial killer called the black hood
earlier in the season Mitch doesn't
quite managed to make it through the
rest of Riverdale 2nd season alive her
fate is sealed when she's cast in
Riverdale High's production of the
musical version of Stephen King's Carrie
when the curtain on the show Rises
audiences and half the town of Riverdale
see a gruesome sight midge brutally
stabbed with creepy messages written in
blood on the wall around her midge may
be gone but she's definitely not
forgotten vixens and I vowed that we
will not rest until those responsible
for the murder of our sister is rightly
punished modern family isn't the ratings
juggernaut it once was and its tenth
season maybe one of its last to bring
back some of the viewers that have tuned
out over the years the show pulled a
little publicity stunts before the
season began promising that a
significant character would die in an
episode to come fans and reporters
speculated about who would be the one to
kick the bucket but no one expected it
to be DD Jays first wife and Mitchell
and Claire's mother deaths on Gotham are
frequent but the victims are usually
just underling Stooges or random
bystanders shockingly two major
characters meet their end in the show's
fourth season finale butch managed to
cheat death once when he was brought
back to life in a toxic swamp but he's
ultimately killed by the penguin as
revenge for Butch's earlier murder of
penguins mother classic Batman villain
Ra's al Ghul also bites the big one in
the season finale after Barbara turns
down the baddies offered to leave Gotham
she stabs him in the chest with the
assistance of Bruce Wayne will Simpson
was a vital character in the first
season of Jessica Jones first a cop
controlled by kilgrave then a love
interest for Trish Walker and then
finally an unstable killer addicted to
super steroid esque pills when season 2
starts up Simpson a stalking Trish he
corners her and gets shot in the leg at
which point he warns Trish that she's in
danger
a useful warning but delivered a bit
late since he's mysteriously killed
minutes after he delivers his warning
Jimmy's tough-as-nails landlord Lillian
found love in the third season of
unbreakable kimmy schmitt with art
Goodman the owner of a whole foods like
grocery chain called big naturals
nothing lasts forever though at the
beginning of season 4 viewers learned
that already died on their vacation and
Lillian was entrusted to spread his
ashes at the site of his summer camp in
Manhattan which had turned into an
exclusive club barred from entering the
club Lillian is able to give Artie the
final resting place he asked for along
with some closure for herself she sells
two plastic baggies full of Artie's
cremated remains to a bunch of finance
pros who clearly think those ashes are
something a little more party friendly
[Music]
shoes if scandal had to end so would one
of its main characters somebody had to
pay for seven seasons worth of political
machinations backstabbing extramarital
affairs politicking terrorism and murder
that person wound up being Attorney
General David Rosen in the penultimate
episode Washington DC fixer Olivia Pope
tells the public about the existence of
the secretive b613 operation hoping that
the revelation would somehow stop sneaky
power-crazed vice president Cyrus
unfortunately that leads the
increasingly unhinged Cyrus to respond
by poisoning Rosen with a deadly
cocktail David Rosen humor are in my way
no hard feelings the second season
finale of the rebooted x-files killed
off a lot of longtime characters one of
the seasons main arcs concerns cigarette
smoking man's plans to unleash a deadly
virus to pull it off he manipulated
Scully's shape-shifting son William
along with FBI assistant director Walter
Skinner and agent Monica Reyes into
helping him execute it smoking man also
happens to be Williams biological father
he was the one who drugged and medically
impregnated Scully nearly two decades
ago William wishing to be free of all
this evil finally confronts his dad on a
dock while using his powers to disguise
himself as Mulder smoking man shoots
William as Mulder in the head right
before the real Mulder arrives to shoot
smoky man and kick him into the water
the deaths don't stop there Skinner
shoots agent Reyes before getting run
over by a car himself luckily it isn't
all doom and gloom
William seems to have survived
[Music]
Fox's new girl isn't so new anymore and
it came to the end of its seven season
run with a handful of episodes to wrap
up all of its loose ends and give each
of its characters a proper send-off alas
a finale usually means somebody has to
die and in this shows case that somebody
would be Ferguson the beloved Smosh
faced cat belonging to Winston while
viewers were saved the not very sitcom
friendly images and emotional turmoil of
watching a pet die new girl devoted an
episode to Winston's over-the-top
grieving process which involves a
motorcade to an elaborate memorial
service conducted in the Jewish
tradition will mourn you until we join
you Ferguson
when the Tim Allen sitcom Last Man
Standing returned to Fox more than a
year after ABC canceled it producers
made a few changes one of the biggest
changes was that Bud Baxter portrayed by
veteran character actor and Oscar
nominee Robert Forester wouldn't be back
at all because in the new season but is
dead Forster shows up here and there on
the ABC version of the show but
producers used the network switch to
send his character to the great beyond
luckily bud still got the opportunity to
appear one last time as a ghostly vision
for closure on some unresolved issues I
tell my kids I love them all the time I
don't think I ever remember you Satan in
May 2000 a teen flame Crawford was
shockingly fired from Fox's TV version
of Lethal Weapon apparently in his two
seasons of work on the show as loose
cannon cop Martin Riggs Crawford made
life difficult on the set for many
people notably co-star Damon Wayans
prior to the third season renewal fans
learned that Crawford would be replaced
by Sean William Scott who would play a
new partner to Wayans Roger Murtaugh
that ramped up speculation as to how
Lethal Weapon would explain Crawford's
sudden absence the show addressed the
issue with its third season premiere
which found Riggs dying from a gunshot
wound he sustained in the second season
cliffhanger of course the body count of
TV characters doesn't in there and
shocker a few more come from that zombie
show where lots of people die all the
time
here are some more familiar faces who
went off to that DVR in the sky Nick
Clark fear The Walking Dead
Tobin The Walking Dead Spencer American
housewife
Madison fear the walking dead Gregory
the walking dead
[Music]